BIG FOCUS HAS BEEN RESTORING LAW
AND ORDER TO AMERICAN CITIES.
CNN HAS CHANGED ITS TUNE
ABRUPTLY, CNN HAS DECIDED
RIOTING IN KENOSHA NEEDS TO STOP
BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE HURTING JOE
BIDEN’S CHANCES OF WINNING.
>> YOU HAVE TO COME OUT AND TELL
PEOPLE HE IS GOING TO DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE OF POLICE REFORM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND THAT WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW IS
HAPPENING UNDER DONALD TRUMP’S
WATCH.
THE RIOTING HAS TO STOP.
CHRIS, AS YOU KNOW AND I KNOW,
IT’S SHOWING UP IN THE POLLS,
IT’S SHOWING UP IN FOCUS GROUPS,
IT IS THE ONLY THING, IT IS THE
ONLY THING RIGHT NOW THAT IS
STICKING.
>> Tucker: IT’S SHOWING UP IN
THE FOCUS GROUPS, QUOTE,
THEREFORE IT MATTERS.
PICTURE DAVIS HANSEN, PROFESSOR,
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING MORE
CYNICAL?
WE NEED TO STOP SHOWING PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT’S SHOWING UP IN THE
FOCUS GROUPS.
>> I THINK THEY THOUGHT JOE
BIDEN WOULD RUN OUT THE CLOCK, 8
OR 9 POINT LEAD, HE WOULD BE IN
THE BASEMENT, EVERYBODY WAS TOLD
TO ALLOW THINGS AS THEY WERE.
DONALD TRUMP OWNED HIM AS THE
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
THEY MADE A DEVIL GAR BARGAIN
WITH BERNIE SANDERS.
THEY’RE SAYING TO BIDEN, WE’LL
PROVIDE THE ANARCHY AND THE
CHAOS, YOU CAN THEN ACCEPT OUR
AGENDA AFTER THE ELECTION WHEN
YOU WIN.
WE GET OUR ENTHU WITH YOU, THEN
YOU PROMISE THE COUNTRY THE
VIOLENCE ENDS.
IT PROBABLY WOULD.
JOE BIDEN IS A PRISONER OF THESE
PEOPLE.
I’M NOT SURE HE CAN RENEGE ON
THE PROMISE.
YOUR NEWS ABC, CNN, NBC, CBS,
YOU AREN’T SAYING WHERE THE
COUNTRY IS.
THE COUNTRY IS GOING ONE WAY AND
THE MEDIA IS SAYING GEORGE FLOYD
DEFUND THE POLICE GOING THE
OTHER, AND BIDEN IS AN ECHO
CHAMBER.
LIKE IF HILLARY THINKING SHE’LL
GET A LANDMARK, UM, LANDSLIDE
MANDATE BY GOING IN TO GEORGIA
AND ARIZONA ON THE EVE OF THE
ELECTION AND BLOWING THE
ELECTION AND HAVING HER BLUE
WALL CRUMBLE.
HE DOESN’T HAVE THE INFORMATION,
HE’S ISOLATED.
NOW THE POLLS ARE FINALLY
SEEPING INTO THESE PEOPLE.
OH MY GOD, THE COUNTRY IS SICK
OF THIS STUFF AND THE POLLS ARE
GOING -- TRUMP’S CREEPING UP IN
THESE OTHER POLLS, FOCUS GROUPS,
AND WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
QUICK.
IT’S NOT BASED ON PRINCIPLE.
THEY MORTGAGED THEIR SOULS A
LONG TIME AGO TO CREATE THE